[Music]
hey there anime fans if you're here
chances are that you've already watched
my video of the top 10 badass moments in
one piece
and if you enjoyed that then you know
why you're here again because it's time
for volume 2.
why well why not one piece is full of
such brilliant moments of
courage spunk attitude and general
badassery
that it just makes sense to make a
second list in this video you're going
to find both one-on-one encounters and
one versus many fights stylish entrances
and moments of quiet strength where
battles are won without raising a weapon
there are moments where the hero doesn't
win for a change and where the villain
shows
why he's the top boss naturally there
are spoilers ahead
at number 10 it's luffy finishing off
rob lucci
after a hard-fought battle that almost
didn't go the straw hat captain's way
the final showdown between the pirate
and the cp-9 agent takes place at the
end of the enemy's lobby arc
which stands out as an emotional arc
that served to cement the deep bond
between the straw hats
luci has the upper hand against luffy
for most of the battle at one moment
it seems luffy's out for the count and
robin's chance of happiness is all but
dashed but usopp's strong words of
encouragement pushed luffy to tap into
hidden reserves of resistance
and stand up to his enemy one last time
it's just enough to get the job done
and it reminds us yet again of luffy's
tenacity and his aversion
to giving up against a stronger opponent
this next moment on our list is all
style and panache as sanji living up to
himself given name of mr prince makes a
timely entrance at crocodile's base to
save his crewmates
luffy and gang are in all kinds of
trouble locked up in a sea stone cage in
a croc infested room that's flooding
fast the key to the cage lies in the
stomach of one very snappy bananawani
using his guile and cunning sanji tricks
crocodile into leaving his base
he then breaks into the flooded room and
with a powerful kick that sends
one gigantic croc out of his way saves
the day
as for sanji's mr prince monika well
surely you would have caught on by now
it's a clever bit of foreshadowing by
the mangaka echiro
oda a not so subtle hint to the
revelation many many arcs later that
sanji's actually a prince of the
vinsmoke family
[Music]
up next is luffy challenging big mom a
second time
before they meet in person the first two
interactions between the upstart and the
yonko are telephonic
during their first exchange at the end
of the fishman island arc
luffy fresh off a big win tells big mom
on the den then mushi that he's not only
eaten all her candy but that he plans to
kick her ass all over the new world
unlike this spur-of-the-moment
provocation his second challenge to her
is more personal and more hostile
imprisoned on whole cake island and
unable to rescue sanji
luffy's in a desperate situation yet he
shows his captain
no fear what's more he treats her with
disdain naturally this infuriates big
one to no end but that's exactly
what luffy wants this time his
declaration of war conveys not the boast
of a kid riding high on a win
but the conviction of a man who knows
what he wants and won't let
anything or anybody get in his way even
if it's the most powerful woman
in the world
[Music]
coming in at number seven is luffy's one
punch takedown of
bellamy
in search of the sky island of skypier
the straw hats arrive in jaya there they
run into bellamy the hyena a
rabble-rousing rookie
before his character development in the
dress roster arc bellamy is a rather
unlikable character
he bullies the weak he's arrogant and
he's full of himself too he runs with a
nasty crew
he taunts and humiliates luffy and zorro
for no good reason but what really puts
him at odds with luffy
is that he doesn't believe in dreams
amongst those who do to him
anybody who believes that skypier and
his city of gold exists
is a fool unfortunately though for
bellamy he also seriously underestimates
luffy taking him for a weakling and his
unwillingness to fight as a sign
of cowardice which earns him a punishing
punch to the face from luffy it's always
satisfying to see a bully get what he
deserves isn't it
the shonen fandom loves a superhero who
can single-handedly fight an entire army
zorro happens to be one such hero when
he's not lost and wondering about the
swordsman of the straw hat pirates can
be an extremely capable
first mate to his captain and crew we
saw his incredible loyalty and
sacrificing heart in the incident with
bartholomew kumar which made our first
list of badass moments but
even before that zoro showed us this
side of his character in whiskey peak
when he single-handedly defeated 100
bounty hunters
including a few of crocodile's top
officers and saved his sleeping
crewmates from their evil designs
his sword skills are enough to confuse
his opponents into thinking he's the
real captain of the crew now that he
treats the fight not as a life and death
situation but as an opportunity to test
out his newly acquired swords
makes him such a badass in our books
we're at the halfway mark now and we
have kizaru making short work of the
supernovas
the star body arc makes an important
turning point in the straw hat's journey
it's where luffy famously punches a
celestial dragon
another moment that made it to our first
list another reason that this makes this
arc significant is that it serves as an
introduction to the supernovas the 11
top
rookie pirates perceived as the next big
threat to the world government their
arrival in sambodi at the same time and
luffy's antics at the slave auction
cause such a stir
that it puts them on a direct collision
course with the marines their army of
pacifistas and admiral kizuru however as
brash and fearless as the rookies are
they soon realize they're no match for
the slow speaking
lightning fast admiral kizuru easily
defeats hawkins
drake apple and urug while the straw
hats escape his wrath only with
rayleigh's timely help kizuru may not be
antagonistic like akainu or aokiji but
he makes for a fascinating and often
unpredictable character
[Music]
next up is sabo revealing his special
technique
dragon's breath you talking
taken for dead after he drowned as a
child luffy's sworn brother returns
during the corridor coliseum tournament
in the dress roster arc
taking luffy's place in the fight he
goes up against such big-name opponents
as diamante and burgess disarming both
of them easily with his unique
dragon claw fist martial arts while
showing the same irreverent and
fun-loving fighting style as his brash
younger brother but it's his display of
dragon's breath that's
truly awe-inspiring imbuing his clenched
fists with haki and punching them into
the ground
sarvo sends a shock wave so great that
he completely destroys the arena
sending his opponents in the audience
floundering it is indeed a worthy
exhibition of power for the second in
command of the revolutionary army and
the man chosen to inherit fire fist
ace's devil fruit powers
[Music]
big mom sake cup this is a quiet moment
of courage that's as powerful
as the flashiest showdown with her
unpredictable temperament and
uncontrollable hunger pangs
big mom's one of the most terrifying
forces in one piece
imagine standing up to her at a time
when her best laid plans are falling
apart and she's ready to lose it
jinbe not only dares to do just that but
gets away with it too as luffy and gang
gay crash the grand wedding on whole
cake island
jinbei once again states his intention
to leave big mom's crew and join the
straw hats the furious yonko intends to
make him pay with his life
but shockingly fails to do so because
the fish man shows absolutely no fear of
her and her powers now this
is an incredibly powerful scene made all
the better with the drama and the
dialogue it just goes to show that there
are a few characters as loyal and strong
as the gentle jinbe
esta
in the runner-up spot we have kaido
one-shotting luffy in their very first
encounter in the wano arc
now we've always known that luffy
doesn't think much about picking a fight
with a bigger
stronger meaner opponent he's done it
before and he does it as soon as he
lands in the land of the samurai where
he's supposed to be keeping a low
profile now while luffy does lend a few
lucky hits on the punch drunk yonko by
going all
out we know he's horribly out of his
league there's just no way he can defeat
the man who can't be killed even by
himself right so it's really no surprise
when kaido sobers up just enough to
knock luffy out with one
devastating smack of his black thunder
club the captain of the straw hats is
out for the count despite being in his
armament haki enhanced gear fourth bound
man form that's just how
crazy dangerous kaido is with the wano
story still unfolding its mysteries we
can't help but wonder if luffy's
actually up to the task of bringing down
the invincible yonko
here
[Music]
and that brings us to number one and
taking the top spot is the post time
skip
monster trio turning the lethal pacifist
into heavy metal trash
since their separation at the hands of
bartholomew kumar two years ago the
straw hats have been on their own
training and powering up so they can
reunite one day and resume their journey
acquire reunions out of the question at
least for luffy
zorro and sanji when the monster trio
meet again it's naturally with the
marines and the pacifistas hot on their
heels
the weaponized cyborgs have given the
straw hats endless trouble
two years ago but this time they're more
prepared for them this scene may not
have the gravitas of a serious battle
it is in fact comical in tone with luffy
lugging around a giant backpack filled
with food yet the display of their
newfound strength and growth in
abilities
still makes for a very special moment
it's the monster trio we've loved
and missed after all only stronger and
better than before
and that's it folks given how full of
meaningful and impactful moments this
series is
we might be able to make a volume three
or even a volume four wouldn't that be
great so if you enjoyed this video give
it a like and let me know
well for the time being i hope you
enjoyed volume two tell me if some of
your favorite moments made it to the
list
you can also drop me a line about any
moment you think should have been on
this list i'd love to hear from you you
can subscribe to vinichu for more top
10s and anime content
and i'll see you in the next video
it